welcome back to New rockstars I'm Winnie
van laningham and with me today is my
very best friend the Brian O'Connor to
my Dominic Toretto the man who owes me a
10 second car and only drinks Coronas
it's Tommy Bechtel let's get it going
the fast X trailer just dropped like a
car with a parachute from an airplane So
today we're taking you frame by frame to
cover all the details you might have
missed and you're gonna get to see us to
react to it oh oh baby we're back Mommy
Rita Moreno baby
oh little Brian's learning to drive
oh he's just a man with a permit oh no
mimosas oh no
I like that he said boo I do too
oh [__] oh he licked his knife I didn't
know we had a knife
and he's in the Christ pose
oh Brie Larson Brie Larson so many
superheroes if you think about it they
kind of are all super they really are I
mean like how how many car accidents
have they all survived serious records
oh my God
oh my gosh this is Raiders of the Lost
darker is goddamn Fast and the Furious
cars why they have to be cars
I hate cars I hate them
Helen Mirren yes yes there's a game in
this movie will there be a sir only
those butts finest butts in any movie
franchise so that it looks like we're
getting some street racing John Cena has
a rocket League
it's Jason Statham doesn't know how guns
work but he's gonna change the hierarchy
of the DCU that's right rock is busy
oh whoa what another car falls from the
police he's fine he just pancakes that
other car or Moby Dick oh [__] he got
Moby Dick he's getting dipped he's
getting [__] Dom's getting [__] down
no never mind his charger is stronger
than 200 baby call me Ishmael
oh hey hey yo why are they both dressed
in white I don't know Angelic Angels
holy dear sweet baby Jesus at the top of
that mountain in Rio yes you know what
the problem with that trailer like that
is I'm gonna get in my Chevy Cruze and
I'm gonna be ripping it around the
streets of Burbank like I'm fast and
furious and it is not gonna be good all
right we gotta get into this thing we
got it so the trailer opens on the
classic fast family house where Rita
Moreno AKA Dom Jacob and Mia's Abuelita
is giving a traditional free dinner
blessing and while we all know Dominic
toretto's heart lies in a tank of
nitrous oxide it's the women in Dom's
life who always get his head back on
straight Dom is of course wearing his
classic Toretto mechanic button up
surrounded by his family tej Roman Dom
ready Han Ramsay and Lil Brian no baby
Brian you know what I like I like to
have energy what I don't like is feeling
like the only way to do that is chugging
a giant energy drink it's a lot easier
just to pop a One-Shot energy chew like
this
but it's like a starburst that helps me
energized one shot Energy Chews are a
healthy convenient energy boosting
supplement candy for gamers athletes
YouTube hosts everybody really each
energy shoe has 75 milligrams of pure
caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional nootropics to give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew and if what you
need is an energy so much as an added
bit of focus one shot also makes Focus
chews these bad boys right here
Focus juice
Focus juice really help with
concentration and give a natural boost
of energy with BCD and E vitamins plus
zinc to help with the immune system and
the amino acid tyrosine both energy
tubes and focus tubes are plant-based
naturally sweetened and designed to give
you the energy and focus you need
without a bunch of fillers and chemicals
get started with one shot energy today
by going to onesotenergy.com new
rockstars for 30 off your order that's
oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for 30
off take one shot Thompson is eight
years old in fast X but the last time we
saw him in fast nine he was only two
years old you age faster and furiouser
in this in this universe now we're in
Dom's garage we see a photo of him and
Letty below a picture of Dom and Brian
from fast forward there's also a first
place racing trophy dated 2021 two years
after the events of fast nine which was
set in 2019 AKA we now know the fast X
main storyline takes place in the future
in 2025. Days of Future
hell yeah there's Dom's classic 1970
Charger RT although Dom's voice over
monologue tells us that little Brian is
afraid for his loved ones lives we do
get to see a brief moment of daddy Dom
teaching his baby boy how to drive I had
a daddy Dom teach me how to drive these
cost a lot of money it costs a lot more
money than this did this dude used to
live his life a quarter mile at a time
but like his buddy Brian before him he's
now a father and a husband he's real
real Stakes to lose if things go south
this year it's about what's important
speaking of important we meet fast axes
villain for the first time it's Jason
Momoa Jason mimosas as we like to call
him I'm always chasing mimosas that's my
secret Dante calls out Dominic Toretto
it looks like he's caught Dom in some
kind of secret basement full of photos
of the family that's nice I like his
secret lair it's just family it's just
Family Photos no one go into my Den
that's where all my secrets are Dante is
the goddamn son of her Hernan Reyes the
Brazilian drug lord that the crew stole
a gigantic save of money from in fast
fat we actually see him standing in the
Gap left by the safe watching Dom and
Brian just drive away with all of this I
love when movies do that when they're
like actually with the camera and Eric
Frost talks about this a lot about like
what what we're seeing is what's caught
on camera but there's all sorts of
things happening beyond the camera in
the world that's being created I love
that like in the world Jason Momoa was
there in a sharp in a linen suit and he
just steps out and he's like hey he took
my safe they sure did a few minutes
later we see the safe crash into Dante's
car on the bridge which launches Dante
out of his vehicle straight into the
drink and with the dcu's future still up
in the air who's to say that this isn't
Aquaman's music origin story yeah I
think it could be cannons unlike our
friend Ghostface from Scream Dante
doesn't wipe his bloody knives on his
shirt his shirt's already busted clean
off his rock hard ABS so he licks that
knife ready for using again gross
disgusting not for me though I lick all
my silverware clean I don't own a
dishwasher what's interesting to me
about this yes is that now Dante is
posing oh yeah as he like blows up Rome
and usually Dominic Toretto is like the
big Christian which is the big let's all
pray before dinner I love that that was
my nickname by the way on my basketball
team the big Christian the big Christian
they chose the name Dante for this
character to be in opposition to
Dominic's like christ-like yeah and yet
he's the one Jesus in out while he blows
up buildings even though she's the devil
and guess who else we're gonna meet oh
Brie Larson's new character Tess who by
the way I've got a little bit of a crush
on we're told she's a rogue operative
from the agency although she warns Dom
that Dante is coming for him with
everything he's got a few moments later
in the trailer we see a blonde figure
aiming a gun it down from behind Dante
and I think that could be Tess
a too Tess will also be related to
someone we've met in a previous film
personally my money's on Cypher oh and
that's just because I'm very shallow and
they both have blonde hair it's true
they do who better infiltrate the family
than her own flesh and blood huh so my
money right here right now a little
Tommy token making some predictions is
that Tess is playing cypher's sister in
fast X but let us know who you think
she'll be related to in the comments it
could be anybody maybe she's Brian
O'Connor's sister oh she could be the
long-lost sister William kiss O'Connor
hey top of the morning to you happily
arm Troopers break into Mia's home and
attempt to kidnap Little Brian likely on
behalf of Dante's orders to hit down
where it'll really hurt him and what's
really cool about this is that when John
Cena as Jacob body slams that trooper
through like three layers of floor he's
actually doing his famous wrestling room
the attitude adjustments
several cities across the globe
Fast Tax is taking us to Italy Brazil
the UK Portugal and Antarctica because
why not you gotta get fast and furious
in Antarctica I'm pretty sure this
flaming metal Indiana Jones and the
Raiders of the Lost ark-esque ball won't
even be the most destructive piece of
architecture in this movie I think
they're taking down something really
historic we've already seen them jump
through three buildings in Dubai that's
a good point I'm pretty sure that they
can take down all of the architecture in
all of these cities combined and
carrying on the grand tradition of
public transportation just being
decimated Steven Spielberg fun fact he
got uh he got into a fight with a bus
and now all of everyone else in
Hollywood is trying to avenge him that's
right just like Dante is trying to
avenge his father in fast X and we are
back to what we were talking about
we didn't even take our ADHD medicine
today we're just winding back in like
the shirt beautiful shirts more on that
later Dom's iconic Dodge Charger is the
Bill of the ball with people dancing all
around it they're shaking their butts
Dom says when it used to be about
winning we race for respect yes they did
while facing down Dante who's wearing a
badass shark tooth necklace they're
really leaning into it right it's just
Aquaman it's just awesome they're just
rebooting Aquaman my name's actually
Arthur my name is Zach another cool
throwback we see Diego's character from
Fast Five and John just hugs him yeah
he's a little snug hug you know being an
actor can be difficult but if you've
been in one of these fast movies and
you're not confirmed dad and even if you
are confirmed even if you are there's a
chance you're getting the call to come
back the big bad is back when Dante's
saying that's the problem with having a
big family how do you choose which ones
you save shut up Dante you don't know
what the torrettos are going through so
we only have the racers line up I get
very excited for this we got Mimosa we
got Dom we got franchise newcomer
Daniella medicure she was rat catcher
too and Suicide Squad stand up and I
believe she'll be in the upcoming
Guardians movie fact check that for me
delete it if it's wrong so we get to see
John Cena like I said returning is Jacob
uh but here he's busting out of a mine
shaft like Back To The Future Three in a
new classic car outfitted with rocket
launchers because why not next we get a
quick moment of the now I guess reformed
Deckard Shaw elbowing someone in the
head maybe a nod to his pal The Rock in
his people's elbow Shaw's back as is his
mother so we had to have the shawls the
good guy's side it really is although
I'm sorry but I would if I had to pick
anybody to like actually street race
with and be best friends with it would
be queenie shop absolutely obviously
Helen mirror absolutely star of all
franchises even though she hasn't been
at all she should be she should she's
gonna save Shazam I'm calling it right
now now go with me here all right
conspiracy we get a quick shot of an
orange muscle car racing a golden
Lamborghini now in the franchise
especially the second movie I believe
first and second Brian O'Connor drives
an orange muscle car and he is very much
alive in this franchise he's alive he's
just a
that we're gonna get some deep fake
technology or maybe just voice
Recreation Tech to include Paul Walker
in this movie you know how important his
legacy is to Vin Diesel oh absolutely
talks about it all the time I mean again
there's no jokes here this is just true
then we get to see Roman and tej kick a
little ass on what looks like the
streets of Rome and Letty treats us to
some sick ass Motocross skills oh God
she sure does now it's personal because
Dante is kidnapped low Brian you don't
do that you don't take the shirt says
protect it's just protect it doesn't say
kidnapped it's not fair it absolutely
would not be a fast movie without a
low-flying cargo plane that you can
drive cars onto or off of I don't know
who Dom's suspension guy is but the fact
that his car can reverse off the back of
a plane Crush two cars and then drive
off is truly remarkable really
incredible and then his car gets hit
with two harpoons from helicopters as is
the tradition but come on they're no
match for Dom's charger and he quickly
gives the helicopters the old meeting of
the mines and drives away from the
wreckage this is where we gotta go a
little bit crazy you and I have been
talking we share this joint conspiracy
we're very excited about it yeah you go
ahead and lay it out okay in the final
scene we're now in a medical facility
where Letty wakes up on a metal slab
next to Cipher and of course they fight
around all of the expensive equipment
right this is what we think is this a
Face-Off scene have they replaced each
other's faces I think that this is face
off I think we're facing I'm about to
see face off not why not make fast 10 a
backdoor Face-Off reboot you know it's
Aquaman it's Peacemaker it's Shazam 2.
it's face off it's a little bit of
Rugrats in Paris oh it's a lot of
Rugrats in Paris y'all if you squint
hard enough
is that the Fable men's I see no it's
not Whitney you're not gonna talk me out
of it I'm not gonna talk you out of it
that's what we're saying this is a
Face-Off okay you heard it here first
and last probably hopefully first and
last that's how you go fast that's right
around well I live my life one breakdown
at a time with you oh I live my life one
trailer breakdown at a time with Tommy
bechtold uh you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter Whitney puppy you
can follow Tommy at Tommy bechtold you
can follow me Rockstar subscribe to me
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye bye
I'm Eric Boss and this is new rockstars
the Deep dive in which I go beyond
hunting Easter eggs so try to decode
what the eggs mean is this Kang variant
truly surprised here or is he performing
a script that requires him to act
surprised
initiating spin
foreign
[Music]